I want to start by apologizing for my
dr. Phil impression it's unprofessional
to do that when a guess is about to come
out that's okay I'll walk around at my
show all the time like this like I've
got a Banzai Pipeline bombs out pipeline
wave on top of my head yeah all right
doing that's called the Conan it's good
and taller actually it does get taller
when I'm aroused it was up because of me
or because of you yes Andy rejected me
so I will now marry you here in
California Way we can tag team or
something
[Applause]
this is either our best or worst show
ever I don't know which one it is that's
a late night doctor yeah so what's up no
no no we're not gonna move on from you
and Andy tag-teaming
[Laughter]
let's talk about sex because when you're
here that's what I like to find out
about is you know about this stuff you
are the man and I just read a statistic
they say that there's a study on
relationships and sex okay and it's just
come out and it says that if there's a
television in the bedroom that sexual
activity drops by as much as 50% 50%
really yes unless you're watching Conan
and it's 75
[Music]
I happen to be an aphrodisiac people put
me on to get things going sometimes no
drop what do you think I just I can't
believe that do you have it you have a
okay so we don't need to see what
happened visuals do you have a TV in
your bedroom yes how's things going well
it's down to six or seven times a week
so it is 50% animal don't you mean with
your wife now you're tagged too we don't
you bet that's true I mean people watch
TV instead of each other and then there
you go yeah you know TV in your bedroom
no I do not I do not know really now I
have an old curved top radio yeah I
listen to sports cast from the 1940s on
it and that's where I ran back then the
fan correction
but I do not have a I do we do not have
a TV in the bedroom and so you think
that couples become the sexual activity
starts when they're just looking at each
other like they're like staring at each
other if you watch on TV you fall asleep
watching TV instead of talking to each
other and you talk to each other then it
leads to other things see what talking's
can often lead to you know especially
been married a while I would say kick
how come the gardener didn't you know
and then you never and then you know
what's wrong with your stupid show I
made a deal I made a deal with my wife
you can't ask me any questions in bed so
if we go to bed now you can't say wait
what happened with this or where'd you
do that or it can ask me any questions
in bed that's a good rule to have you
should try that you know this is this is
interesting no questions you know
questions is what can you say just
statements like this just affirmative
statements permanent statement yeah like
here's what I want you to do tomorrow 1
2 3 4 5 when you get your marching order
here's what I want you to do tonight
dressed like a matador I'm revealing too
much about myself doctor